this video is about the
mean after this video you know
what the mean is and what types
of mean there are
so let's start right away with the first
question what is the mean choose the
mean is the sum of all
observations divided by the number
of observations
so if we have the values ​​x1 of the xm
then we simply add them up and
divide them by the number of values
here first the mean value
is the display values ​​and xii is the
value at the same point in the first
step let's look at it again
hand an example and then we'll go
through what else there are for mean values,
strictly speaking, that's the formula for
the arithmetic mean
so let's get to the example,
let's say we asked six people about
their height the first person is
a meter 73 tall the  second person is
a beta 47 tall third person one
meter fifty fourth person one
meter 63 fifth person
146 u  nd the sixth person a tenant 61
if we sort the height of each
person we can now easily take
the mean the mean
is
147 plus 150 plus 160
146 plus 165 divided by the number
of people in this case we have
six people  so divided by 6
that equals 930 divided by six so
we get an average value of 155 cm
so on average this person has a
height of 155 centimeters so the
question now is what other
average values ​​there are
other known average values ​​are still
the square mean  and the
geometric mean the root mean square is
calculated by dividing the
individual data squares and
then summing
them up by the number of cases and taking the roots of this the
geometric mean is
calculated by multiplying all the values ​​and
from which the duck short is calculated with
it  can you now calculate the arithmetic
mean square  che mean and the
geometric mean if you now
want to calculate the mean value online you can of
course do this at datatec for
this simply go to date up de
copy a data in this table
and select the variable house from which you
want to have the mean value
then the del  club very simply, for
example, for income or
age, the mean value from depending on
which variable you clicked on
above, and now a tip from me
if you want to understand the statistics quickly and easily
and don’t want to be
afraid of statistics anymore, just have a
look  our book statistics made
easy we explain the days with
many examples and many graphics
everything you need to know and the statistics
the book is the perfect basis for
the state will be a data analysis
you will find the link in the video
description so I hope you liked the video
Pleased and we'll see you
next time bye